قد تكون الطائرات المسيره المدنيه مجرده
اداه للتصوير الاحترافي او الترفيه
بالنسبه لمعظم مستخدمها لكن بحسب بوليتكو
يبدو ان الطائرات المسيره الصينيه لها
اغراض اخرى حيث باتت هذه المسيرات رقيبه
ربما على المجال الجوي الاكثر امانا في
العالم ونعني بذلك العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن
واكدت ان اسرابا من هذه الطائرات صينيه
الصنع عكرت صفوه سمائي واشنطن واثارت
بوجودها مخاوف لدى وكالات الامن القومي في
ان تصبح وسيله للتجسس
وبنيه المزاعم استنادا الى مقابلات مع
سبعه من المسؤولين الحكوميين في الكونجرس
الذين اكدوا انهم لاحظوا اكثر من 100
عمليه في فتره الايام ال 45 الاخيره
ووافقه صحيفه فان هذه الطائرات لاستطلاعيه
تصنعها شركه دي جي اي الصينيه وهي اكبر
شركه مصنعه للطائرات من دون طياره شخصيه
والمهنيه في العالم وتشكل منتجاتها غالبيه
الطائرات الترفيهيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
من قبل الحكومه الصينيه الا انها تمثلون
في انتشار الطائرات من دون طياره رخيصه
نسبيا ولكنها متطوره بشكل يتجاوز
استخدامها حدد ترفيه والتجاره وعلى حد
تعبير رعشه ستون نائبه رئيس البرامج
البحثيه في مركز سمسم فهذه الطائرات تتمكن
من جمع بيانات هائله قد تكون للوهله
الاولى قد تكون مهماتها بريئه وغير منهجه
لكنها بالتاكيد قد ينتهي بها الامر لمستوى
اكثر خطوره
بالرغم من ان الشركه المصنعه تؤكد
التزامها ببرمجتها هذه المسرات بالقيود
التي تمنعها من التحليق فوق المناطق
الامنيه
[موسيقى]